GOALTENDER FELIX SANDSTROM, SIX
PLAYER
LOOKING TO SPIN AWAY FROM FORMER
FLYER JUSTIN BRAUN.
OU
>> Kenny: SCOTT LAUGHTON.
LAUGHTON WITH IT ONCE .
VAN RIEMSDYK WITH THE PUCK.
>> Kenny: REPLACIN
SCORE, AND THE FLYERS WOULD WIN
THAT GAME IN A SHOOT-OUT JUST
HERE COMES STROME.
STROME FROM MILLER.
THE FIRST RANGER.
NOW CONNAUYORK.
>> Kenny: IN
POSITION.
TROUBA TRIES TO TAKE IT
SEASON JOINING JAROMIR JAGR.G CE
BY CHRIS KREIDER ON THE TURNOVER
BY HAYES.
THAT'S WHERE THE F F.
OFCK.
HUNT KEPT IT AWAY FROM KEITH
YANDLE, BACK IE MIDDLE, ONTO
KAKKO AGAIN, HE SCORESY KAAPO K
AS HE SNAPS IT HOM KAAPO KAKKO.
>> Keith: IT'S BEEN A WHILE,
FR.
>> Kenny: FOST RUS.
FAMOUS AROUND HERE, JUST.
FILIP CHYTIL WITH TH
PROV
LOOK HOW WIDE OPEN THAT IS,
KENNY.
ZAMULA CHASING THE PUCK DOWN.ISS
LINDBLOM OVER AS WELL.
ACROSS NOWE FIRST OF OUR NHL ON
DOUBLE-HEADER,
SHORT-HANDED.
NO ONE ELSE IN THE HISTORY OF
THE LEAGUE HAS DONE THATT IT TH.
TROUBA IN HIS THIRD SEASONS KRE
PULLED FOR THE FLYERS AND AN
THAN STAYING HEALTHY AND GETTING
READY FOR THE NEXTS THE CREASE
AND AN